[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior s'est rendu sur le site de
l'académie des dalons bernicat afin de
rencontrer les jeunes femmes de la
promotion de 18
l'académie des dalons un dispositif
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
mise en place par le conseil
départemental qui a pour but de redonner
confiance aux jeunes en favorisant le
développement personnel et citoyens
chacun arrive ici avec des des histoires
avec cette douleur ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire un travail sur soi et moi je
salue le travail réalisé par toute
l'équipe pédagogique autour du directeur
se calmer point vraiment souligner qu'
un travail formidable qui est fait et
les résultats sont positifs
donc bravo félicitations à tous ces
jeunes
je trouve que dans leur vie de tous les
jours bien sûr il ya des difficultés
mais quand je vois ce dont ils sont
capables de faire et de dire eh bien
nous sommes rassurés
bravo et félicitations et surtout je le
souhaite plus belle réussite pour la
suite de leur carrière
les jeunes volontaires intègre
l'académie durant un an dont trois mois
d'internât ils sont encadrés par des
professionnels qualifiés afin de leur
permettre de se responsabiliser et de
devenir autonome
ce qu'on propose à l'académie n'est
d'annoncer déjà de se poser de regarder
un petit peu quelles sont les
motivations de la personne ses
ressources ses compétences et puis après
on se met au travail
et quand la la confiance est là quand
les gens se sont mis dans des situations
de réussite dans des situations de
dépassement quand les personnels sont
allés au delà des limites qu'il leur
pensait qu'elle pensait voilà et lorsque
ses limites bas elles sont dépassées par
des étapes de maturation et là on
commence à parler du mot projet et ça
prend du sens pour la personnes des
jeunes pour la plupart en difficulté
sociale et déscolarisés ils vont en
l'académie des dalons une véritable
seconde chance
ça m'apporte énormément de choses va en
fait si on nous encadrent pendant trois
mois et
vient un peu sans repères et du coup on
fait main le fait d'être encadrés par
des éducateurs et des directeurs
d'établissements franchement c c'est
quelque chose qu'on retombe pas en fait
forcément dans d'autres structures
voilà et c'est important fait pour notre
notre vie active au niveau professionnel
et niveau développement personnel aussi
ben j'avais une part important scolaire
et général très chaotique et j'avais
besoin de repères et d'être cadré avons
plus de maturité de confiance en moi et
une posture professionnelle un peu plus
correct matin durant les trois mois un
internat la totalité des frais tels que
la restauration les cours les transports
ou encore l'hébergement sont prises en
charge par la collectivité
[Musique]